[Music]
foreign
here in this video we will showcase all
the nuclear pulse attacks of Godzilla in
live action movies and then later before
we end the video we will rank which one
was the best so let's get to it number
one in Godzilla vs biolante so Godzilla
arrives drawn by the presence of his
cells within bailand's body as the two
kaijus Fades off biolante immedially
takes the initiative attacking Godzilla
with his tendrils and using his
corrosive sap to inflict damage its pure
tip generals Pierce Godzilla's skin and
spews corrosive sap and tangling and
constricting the G-Man and this is where
we see Godzilla unleash the nuclear
pulse for the first time as he charges
it up like a normal Atomic breath but
unleashes it like a shock wave in all
directions through cracks from his body
effectively tearing down all the its
near intendrils
so in Godzilla vs King Ghidorah Time
Travelers come and warn of Godzilla's
return and therefore aim to prevent his
creation by altering history they placed
three cute little genetically engineered
dorads on Lagos Island causing them to
become King Ghidorah due to nuclear
exposure then the new King Ghidorah
begins to wreak havoc in Japan in
response the present government tries to
recreate Godzilla using a nuclear
submarine however unbeknownst to them
Godzilla still exists and absorbs the
sub's energy gaining enough power to
clash with King Ghidorah it is here that
we see Godzilla use the nuclear pulse
again to break free of ghidorah's
strangling necks the Shockwave was so
powerful it sent a 150 meter
three-headed dragon a long way away
in Godzilla vs Mothra during the
climatic battle scene mother and batra
teamed up to confront Godzilla and they
attempted to subdue him using their
combined abilities Mothra releases
scales from her wings that recreates a
3D mirror around Godzilla deflecting his
Atomic breath trapping him inside this
strategy allows them to gain the upper
hand momentarily by preventing Godzilla
from using his devastating Atomic breath
Godzilla responds with a powerful
nuclear pulse to execute this attack
Godzilla charges up energy within his
body and then releases it in a burst
that radiates outwards in all directions
creating a shock wave of nuclear energy
repelling both flying kaijus and
destroying the 3D mirror
so in Godzilla vs destoroya throughout
the movie Godzilla's meltdown serves as
a ticking Time Bomb creating a sense of
urgency and an impending doom on the
planet in the climatic battle Godzilla
faces off against a fully evolved
Destroyer the nuclear pulse was a burst
of energy that emanated from Godzilla's
body creating powerful shock waves that
obliterates everything in their path and
vicinity the pulse is so intense that it
disintegrates the smaller Destroyer
creatures in the vicinity and this boss
was even deadlier when it came out in
constant waves from his dorsal plates
annihilating everything ultimately his
nuclear pulse combined with some help
enabled him to kill destroya and burning
him into Ash however the victory comes
at a great cause as Godzilla succumbs to
his own meltdown
in the movie Godzilla 2000 Millennium so
starting Orga was a mutated entity
created by the DNA of Godzilla and an
alien species attempting to absorb
Godzilla's genetic material and
transform into a more powerful form when
Orga and the Big G fought it was clear
that the only Advantage the alien
monster had was his fast regenerative
ability so Godzilla allowed it to try
and swallow him whole but Godzilla
releases a massive Atomic Shockwave that
engulfs Orga completely obliterating its
upper body and leaving only headless
remains behind the intense blast causes
Orga to erupt in flames and eventually
explode and burn to Ash
so in Godzilla King of the Masters the
G-Man once again faced off against his
age-old rival the titular monster was
pushed to his limit in their final
showdown in Boston up against a
supercharged King Ghidorah the Big G was
badly wounded after being dropped from
the sky like a piece of dragon turd
Mothra then interrupted and attacked
Ghidorah only to be morally wounded so
after giving what's left of her Essence
a Life Force to Godzilla and she
vanished and then Godzilla entered into
his burning form now as burning Godzilla
he was impervious to master Zero's
attacks and in this form he released a
series of nuclear pulses that vaporized
a large section of the city of Boston
along with a three-headed dragon and in
the pulses you can see you can clearly
see the design of the wings of Mothra
now in Godzilla final Wars the G-Man
also displayed a minor variant of the
nuclear pulse when he was fighting
against Kaiser Ghidorah at first in the
decimated area of Tokyo Godzilla face
off against an enemy called Monster X
which was somehow Palm for power as
strong as the Big G but when it
transformed into Kaiser Ghidorah it
clearly had the upper hand and started
to drain Godzilla's life force so with
the help of the Ozaki firing Kaiser
energy into Godzilla our favorite lizard
showcased a tiny new type of nuclear
pulse which was used to separate
ghidorah's head from Godzilla's body
which was sucking the life out of him
and then the usual Godzilla ends
Ghidorah in a blaze of glory
so this is our pick out of the seven
from the least to the best at the bottom
we have the final wars minor pulse then
the one versus King Ghidorah where it
wasn't a final attack but merely another
side ability after that we ranked the
one against biolante as better than the
previous one since it was the first time
we saw it then we come to the one he
uses against Mothra and batra destroying
the 3D mirror and now for the best three
we would definitely pick the one versus
Agra in the third spot for its awesome
blast staring apart the alien Kaiju as
for the second spot we will give it to
the most of us for its let's say
cinematic Beauty and the best nuclear
pulse in our case is the one he uses
against destoroya which was so extreme
that it went out of control ending in
both destroyals and Godzilla's death
while at the same time Reviving Godzilla
Junior and giving us a sense of urgency
and crisis for the Doom of the planet
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit the like button for support
and subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates and new
videos here on this channel till the
next one take care fam